president zielinski has just arrived in
the United Kingdom ah we've just got the
news this is not a huge surprise because
president zielinski was of course in
Germany and saying he's going to arrive
but I think he's already here isn't he
but um we expect that he'll be seeing
Rishi sunak today and this will be his
third visit to the UK since the War
Began he was here meeting Rishi sunak uh
in February and of course I was here
last year as well and we expect of
course he is touring European capitals
to make the case for them to help
Ukraine acquire the fighter jets that he
says it needs in order to defeat Russia
as we expect this counter-offensive is
going to gather pace so we expect he
will be speaking with Richie CNAC today
yeah I'm just looking at his uh tweets
today London the UK is a leader when it
comes to expanding our capabilities on
the ground in the air this Corporation
will continue today I will meet my
friend Rishi we will conduct substantive
negotiations face to face and in Del
allegations always been very quick to
comment about the UK hasn't he and and
he feels that the UK is driving Europe
into helping Ukraine still further very
much so and you can see in the visits
that he makes that he considers that
very important he hadn't gone to Germany
since the conflict began but did go
yesterday after they announced a
military aid package uh worth over 2
billion pounds um he's seen that under
Boris Johnson are now under which he's
seen at the UK has been leading the
charge to send more Weaponry to Ukraine
the defense secretary has made a few
announcements on that in the last few
weeks and I'm sure we will get questions
for the two of them today about
um fighter jets and about how how far
off that is from becoming a reality okay
let's have a quick look at that tweet
should we that we've just seen um or
just read out I should say from
president zielinski today London the UK
is a leader when it comes to expanding
our capabilities on the ground and in
the air this cooperation will continue
today I will meet my friend Rishi not
even sudok we will conduct substantive
negotiations face to face and in
delegations
um went to uh we've seen him in Germany
of course Italy as well I believe France
last night that's right yes he's touring
um the capitals of the Allies who are
helping Ukraine and he was asked
yesterday actually about um's reports in
the U.S media that Ukraine was thinking
of attacking Russian Targets in order to
put pressure on the leadership in Moscow
he denied that yesterday saying that
Ukraine is going to be fighting to
liberate its own territory but in order
to do that it needs the support of its
allies it needs Military Support